صعودا وهبوطا تنتقل بخفه وسحر بين ثنايا
اللحن بصوتها العبد اما لو تعرف تدين لها
بمساحه خاصه لا تنبسط شاسعه الا حين تكون
هي فارسه الجواد فنانه جابت الثقافات
ومزجت بينها فحضر في صوتها الحلاج والرومي
والمتنبي غنت ولحنت وترجمه قصائد البستها
ثوب العربيه مطرزا باهاتها وحلياتها فصارت
ملاذا دافئا لكل من يفتقد لللغتنا فنانه
استثنائيه باداء اكبر من الكلمات لتكون
قادره على ضمها واوسع من الافق الذي
يشبهها كثيرا انها ضيفتنا اليوم الفنانه
جاهده وه به
كثيرين
في لبنان
قيتم كثير
يعني دايما النغم هو حياتي وبعتقد انه
كلنا مع الفنون الفنون تعطي لحياتنا بعد
اخر وهي بتساعدنا على يعني بظل كل اللي عم
نعيشه تاخدنا على مطرح اخصب وانقى واشهى
على موروثاتنا بسبب العولمه ما اكثر ما
يقلقك ويخيفك الحقيقه انا بعتبر انه نحن
كامم ضعيفه نسبيا في ظل هذه العولمه اللي
بلشت عم تبلعنا فاذا لم نكن متنبهين
ومنتبهين الى موروثنا الثقافي والحضاري
وربما سعينا اكثر الى ارشفته وادخاله في
هذا البعد الرقمي فرح يندثر تباعا خاصه
وانه عم نحاول يعني انا بشوف نحن فنانين
دائما عنا هاجس التشبه بالغرب او انه
نستنسخ منه بدل ما نحن نصدر له نحن عنا
موروث وافر وغنيه جدا جدا جدا فلماذا
التشبه بالغرب وبالاخرين علينا نحن نعطيهم
الموروثنا علينا نحافظ نخلي هذه الصله
الرحم الرباط موصول مع تراثنا قد ما قدمنا
يعني جديد ومعاصر ومعاصر ما لازم ننسى
هويتنا وثقافتنا هويتنا الحضاريه كتير
مهمه سيده جاهده قلتي مره محاول ان اصل
الى الروح واخاطب الوجدان من خلال اليوم
نحبك تخاطبي وجدان صباح العربيه وتسمعينا
شي صوتك مسمعكم شو بدنا نسمعكم بقول لكم
مقطع من العمل اللي قدمناه ليله 30052
بالمجمع الثقافي من
جبران ايضا بالمحكيه بيت بالمحكيه مش
معروف كتير انه هو لجبران خليل جبران
بيقول
هيهات
يا ابو الزين
عيني
يموت لن
محلى الوباء
[موسيقى]
وماح عايزه بيه
هو الله
يطوف النهر
وتحاومي
ليل وادي
وبعمل
زنودي
جاسر
لا هيا
وقلنا خلفوك يابا فوق النخل
فوق مدري لا
حتى يابا
[موسيقى]